today's topic i got this i saw this
video on ig i can't help it
it's something you do to protect the
people you care about if you don't give
a [ __ ] you would just go sleep with
whoever
if you cheat that's showing that you're
taking the steps to protect other
people's feelings i've never been caught
i develop these habits i would go to the
bathroom to take a shower
every day when i got home i didn't
really want to take multiple showers in
a day but i know that if i was coming
home from cheating that it was going to
be a necessity i didn't need to look
out of the ordinary i'd always have a
friend and they will help to stretch out
my lies
we'll take even some pictures together
that might not be on that day and i'll
save these pictures and i'll even post
them to maybe a snapchat i'll block
everybody from the story but her so she
has like this personalized story
i've done some things that have thrown
her off i saved my sister's name and my
phone is beautiful girl because i knew
it with a tractor to go through it and
my sister told me about you know your
girl called me
so it worked out so i was able to
confront her and say why would you go
through my phone
she said why you have her in there is
beautiful girl i said that's just a
nickname i've had for her whole life
it just made her feel like wow like i
shouldn't have been going through his
phone i've been with my girl for about
five
years when i got with my girl i already
had a
baby on the way i didn't want her to
know about that so i couldn't be honest
with her from the beginning
my baby mother thinks i live in
transitional housing and i actually
been living with this girl for five
years because i can't afford for her to
put me on child support the process
servers could come looking for me at the
address that i'm at we all live in
within like 20 minutes from each other
they can't come to my house because i
live in transitional housing
i have structured my instagram to
attract new women constantly to make
myself seem like a ladies man and it
works
i started talking to girls and giving
them like a proposition like help make
me popular
take a picture with me post it that made
it seem like we had more of a
relationship than what we really did you
know it's going to be like a little
financial incentive of course they
didn't get anything
when i see my male friends go out with a
girl and she's pretty
i'll have them send me the video and
it'll look like i'm taking that pretty
girl out to eat and i'll post that on my
page as well
i would imagine they're thinking wow
he's sitting here and he's getting the
attention from these really beautiful
girls these women see something in me
and you need to come and find out what
that is
let me make this i i i have
zero commentary to make this man
i thought it was operating on such a
high level i thought it would
i thought it was a video about this this
is another thing
bruh if this is acting he is a
phenomenal actor
i have some pictures with my kids on the
instagram so if it's you're looking for
somebody who takes care of his family it
looks like i do more for my kids than
what i actually do and that's what i
want to portray if you're looking for
somebody that goes out and has fun
and take you out and change your life
that could be me they don't know
until after the fact on instagram i will
not let my girl follow me
when i first got with her i got into an
argument about social media and i told
her you need to add me right now
instagram and facebook but that's before
it got really good before i started
doing my stuff she's like you know i'm
not gonna be your friend
now she wants to go back on that but i
said no you need to stand on what she
said all those years ago
and my page is private so she can't see
what's going on i maybe only sleep with
maybe one to two girls at a time
and then i maybe have maybe 10 to 15
girls that i talk to that might be able
to get interchanged into that when i do
go to cheat
i like to take them places where i know
that there's not going to be the other
girls that i talk to
movie theaters because it's dark if i
can get away with getting chick-fil-a
and going to the beach i will because i
know i'm not going to spend over 20 30
when sex get involved i can manipulate a
lot better
i think sex is more of like a tool for
like getting to where you want
what could i get from it maybe it's a
new job somewhere
i've had several girls buy me cars
within the last few years and i've
explained it off to my girlfriend like
where i got this other car
from
this is sick this [ __ ] is sick bro
nah that's fake it's fake that's fake
what is his face i can't no that's fake
he's doing all this
so why is he putting it out there right
now yeah kids
he has kids and he can't be seen
transitional and the way social media
works right now
if they live 20 minutes from around you
[ __ ] are going to tag you
see it doesn't make sense it doesn't
make sense depending on how low their
self-esteem is will depend on how easy
it is to get them to
not pay attention to my shortcomings and
the bigger that they are
the better it is for cheating at least
because they'll accept whatever they get
lizzo kind of [ __ ] up the game with
that because she's really empowered
the body positivity movement it made all
these fat women just feel like they're
like legit like
somebody special so that's a growing
problem that i ran into
it's confident fat woman i do enjoy fat
women for cuddling but
my favorite is like um if she's had like
the gastric bypass because she'll have
the self-esteem of a fat girl but the
body of
a fit girl so it's like the best of both
worlds
i know this is real enough i don't even
care anymore this is crazy i've been
with some super conservative women and
then i'll have conservative opinions
and then when i'm with women that are
like really on the far left like i
personally don't care about things
either way
but i know how to tailor my opinions i
would just say whatever i have to say to
appeal to anybody their music their
political ideologies
sometimes you start to genuinely care
about these people and you want to
share your own opinions and your own
world views and i try not to do that
because
that messes up the finesse for instance
i was with the girl and
i was agreeing with a political opinion
that she had
but it wasn't what i really felt and it
started to cause a rift between us but i
was able to recognize what i was doing
and then go back to having the same
opinions and thoughts that she had and
it was able to put us back on the right
track i do lose sight of what i'm doing
sometimes because sometimes there's some
really
bad people there stealing stuff out of
the cell check out lines
they're not taking good care of their
children they're just really bad people
and i have to just sit up and ignore
these things because i've realized like
i'm here for a reason i'm here to do
something for myself
okay this is a page which i think
interviews people who do all kinds of
crazy stuff
apparently he was one of them okay
drinking muggings breaking into people's
cars i regret my plastic surgery
aging is a choice he doesn't even have a
huge social media following i think this
is real
i was actually leaning towards you i
think this is real i think this is real
judging by the rest of this page
scamming women
judging by how he was explaining in the
lack of remorse in his face
i think he might have some kind of
disorder to be honest with you
if gaslight was someone but do you
understand
i think i think you're saying i think he
has legitimately disorder
it's not the fact that he did i really
felt there's a lot of people who do
stuff like what he does
yeah for me it's a lack of remorse how
candid he was yeah
and how straight he was with it that was
crazy as far as the behavior goes when
you're in the hockey that's trash
but [ __ ] yeah like you said i'm beside
myself it's like watching a murderer
casually tell you how he like chopped up
and killed people it's like
i don't have anything insightful to say
at first i was like you know okay
it's not even about cheating it's about
how la la la la la he is about it yeah i
don't even think he thinks he's i don't
know what he thinks about himself
i think it's like it is what it is you
know it's like when i say video about
like a gold digger they think that what
they're doing
is um right and justified and moral
yeah so that's when i'm confused because
i'm like huh this man's like no i know
he knows it's bad what does he though he
said at the beginning he said
it's the right thing to do if you care
about somebody i think he's just so
twisted that's crazy he thinks he's
doing a good thing if you care about
someone
you'll cheetah bro i have nothing to say
there's so many stuff that i'm back here
hey man listen i wish i had better
commentary if you guys i'm just blown
away by this
super crazy super crazy
hey ladies you fill in the blanks
comments below let me know because i uh
i'll think about this one for a minute
that's crazy it's real do you really
believe it's real now right i understand
why you say it's real but i still got
doubts
look at the rest of the page i
understand i i saw i saw
argue i saw sleep pour state
now you see this page looks real if it's
not
the acting is unbelievable unbelievable
so shut up
i could be wrong if i'm wrong
[Music]
oh